in 2019 a Hollywood classic is also
celebrating its 25th anniversary I'm
talking about one that I have seen
Morris got only we were with Gary Sinise
who continues to keep lieutenant Dan's
memory alive gosh
25 years warning sir get your hands down
I had a great time working with Tom none
of us really knew what it was gonna turn
into and then it would be the big hit
that it was et was with Gary back in
1994 all of a sudden I mean something
that people are actually gonna see
enforced I never thanked you for saving
my life
this 63 year old earned an Oscar
nomination but seven years later the
role of Lieutenant Dan would change his
life again in another big way
I remember going into the first hospital
to visit a wounded soldier after
September 11 and all he wanted to talk
about was Lieutenant Dan and what
happened to Lieutenant Dan it was that
moment that inspired Gary to dedicate
his life to serving veterans and
military families in 2011 he started the
Gary Sinise Foundation which raises 30
million dollars each year one of the
programs is the snowball Express and we
were at the airport with Gary for the
big send-off we're taking over a
thousand children to Disneyworld
we're four days of fun right before the
holidays we have 12 airplanes going from
all around the country each one of these
children has lost a parent in military
service so when we bring all those kids
together they get to bond with each
other it's very very healing if they see
that they're not alone going through
this grief by themselves and we just
give them a lot of love and a lot of joy
and we make sure that they know that
they're appreciated and we don't forget
what they're going through
say hello to Mickey Mouse for me when
you get there god bless you everybody
have fun
[Music]
[Applause]